konami might be working on new metal
gear silent hill and castlevania games
the ps5 now has an 8k game but with a
catch and the stranger of paradise demo
is out now i'm persia happy friday and
welcome to your gamespot news
details have come to light regarding
future games from konami after an
internal restructure and soul searching
within the company konami reportedly
chose to ramp up premium game
development and this will include new
installments and remakes and some of its
franchises including metal gear
castlevania and silent hill this
information comes from reporter andy
robinson who shared the details during
the vgc off the record podcast robinson
said the castlevania game is a
reimagining of the series and that an
internal studio in japan is developing
it alongside external partner studios
additionally a remake of metal gear
solid 3 snake eater is early in
development and virtuous is working on
this game finally multiple silent hill
games are now in the works one of which
has been outsourced to a prominent
japanese developer robinson said all of
these new projects will begin to be
announced in 2022 gamespot has contacted
konami in attempt to get more details on
this story and we'll be sure to let you
know more as soon as we do
ps5 owners may recall that the console's
box boasts that it has the capacity to
display 8k games today a game finally
put the full power of the ps5 to that
test
well
sort of the taurus is the first ps5 game
claiming to support 8k 60fps although
digital foundry has pointed out that
that's not technically what's happening
while the taurus renders internally at
ak resolution the ps5 doesn't actually
support that output over hdmi 2.1
instead according to digital foundry's
report developer shin and multimedia is
using an extreme super sampling
technique to downsample every pixel on a
connected 4k tv the developer has
promised that if sony were to eventually
enable ak output on a ps5 it would
release a patch allowing the tourist to
display without down sampling on an ak
tv as digital foundry notes though an
update for either the ps5 or xbox series
x that lets the consoles display at 8k
probably isn't coming anytime soon ak
devices are far too uncommon in consumer
markets and the number of games that
actually support that kind of output is
at the moment on ps5 just one
team ninja's new final fantasy game
stranger of paradise final fantasy
origin will launch in march of 2022
square enix announced during its tokyo
game show live stream that the game will
arrive on march 18th for pc ps5 and xbox
series xns as well as ps4 and xbox one
additionally a second demo was announced
and it's out right now if you want to
give it a try you can download it on ps5
and xbox series x and s the demo will be
available until october 11th and square
enix will also send a survey to
participants asking for their feedback
gamespot's phil hornshaw played the
second demo and wrote about the
extensive job system that gives you a
ton of tactical combat options you can
check out that full preview on
gamespot.com
for those planning to play a little bit
a new world over the weekend be careful
because there's already reports from
players that the game is breaking their
system so be safe and happy gaming thank
you so much for tuning in and of course
we will catch you next time see ya
[Music]
you